greetings fellow earthlings today we're
gonna talk about the technology within
Star Trek that has become true today
Star Trek is known for predicting tons
of technological achievements such as
cell phones Bluetooth flat-screen TVs
Skype iPads and talking computers and
low computer
all of these gadgets existed in the Star
Trek universe far before they became a
reality and now we're going to update
you on the new developments in
technology the first item on our list is
something you've probably already heard
of virtual display aka Google glass it's
Star Trek members of the super evil
group of the Dominion didn't bother
using flat-screen monitors to surf the
web but a trippy looking headset with
one eyepiece that projected computer
imagery through their optic nerve and
into their brain they could watch
streaming video of the outside of the
ship receive messages and video chat
with other evil Dominion leaders just
like Google glass next let's revisit a
classic that's finally being made today
the medical tricorder that would prove
to have virtually no limitations in
terms of scanning it is most famous for
its ability to diagnose pretty much
anything today's equivalent of
tricorders are capable of diagnosing
most ailments in the human body without
needing to see a doctor just by placing
it on your left temple
this scanadu scout can provide results
for pulse transit time heart rate
temperature blood oxygenation and more
diagnosing anything from abdominal
cramps to shingles it's quite an upgrade
from your thermometer next up on our
list and overlooked essential for all
interstellar space travel transparent
aluminum what did you think space
windows were made of when the Enterprise
crew traveled back to 1986
Scotty handed over the formula for
creating the super strong yet incredibly
thin glass that proved to hold up
against nearly everything the universe
through it not just a ticket laddie
juda Scotty's interference with the
timeline transparent aluminum armor is
now marketed as a law by this sir meant
corporated the armor can resist a 50
caliber armor-piercing bullet and
anti-aircraft weapons while being half
the weight and thickness of typical
bulletproof glass okay
let's move on to something that will
truly change your life computer
one slice of New York cheesecake the
food replicator
it's the biggest menu the fastest
delivery and will probably make you gain
50 pounds of you own one the food
replicators featured in Star Trek
reproduced any foodstuff programmed into
its database with a single voice
blending the replicator to make anything
you desire how do I know what I desire
and the real version looks like this
okay it's not quite as fast but it's
freshly made food at the touch of a
button
just recently NASA has commissioned a
design of a 3d food printer capable of
making pizza in space to satisfy the
indulgence --is of the astronauts which
is the best use of tax dollars happy
with our list well please